[موسيقى]
يرمى القمر مضاء خمسين بالمئه ما يزيد ولا
ينقص ونشاهده هلالا وتربيعا وبدرا ففي اول
الشهر يعطينا ظهره المظلم مرحله الاستقرار
وفي منتصف الشهر يعطينا وجهه المضاء مرحله
الابدار وبينهما يعطينا جنبه مراحل
الترابيع والقمر له ظهر وله وجه اظهاره لم
يشاهده الا رواد الفضاء ووجهه يشاهده جميع
الناس بزوايا مختلفه وظهر القمر لا يشاهد
البته على الرغم من انه يدور حول نفسه ليش
لان دورانه حول نفسه مساويه لدورانه حول
الارض مثل اللي يطوف حول الكعبه حقيقه انه
يدور حول نفسه ويدور حول الكعب وجنبه
الموازي للكعبه لا يتغير لا تصير مثل
القمر له وجهين خليك مثل الشمس له وجه
واحد وواضحه فالشمس لا تغطى
بغربال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وشهر الهجري يبدا هلالا بعيده مغيب شمسي
غربا وينتهي هلالا قبيل شروق شمسي شرقا
كلنا نحب القمر والقمر بيحب مين حظنا منه
النظر والنظر راح يرضي مين
[موسيقى]